good morning after months of wrangling
and hundreds of hours of talks which is
sunak is expected to shake hands on a
deal to cut red tape and make trade
easier across the Irish sea he meets EU
president Ursula Von de Lyon in Windsor
at lunchtime to finalize the agreement
over the Northern Ireland protocol but
he could face a major challenge to sell
the deal to skeptical Ulster unionists
and Tory back benches let's get more
should we tomorrow standing by in
Berkshire Joe Pike is outside Stormont
in Belfast um tomorrow to you first of
all if I may wire there
morning Kate well this is the location
here in Berkshire where Rishi sunak will
be the EU commission boss Ursula
vonderlein who is flying over to the UK
today to we expect sign off the brexit
deal that they have spent many weeks and
hundreds of hours negotiating if you
thought brexit had already been done
well this looks to be the final piece of
the puzzle how post-brexit trade
Arrangements apply in Northern Ireland
and fixing some of the many problems
that have Arisen from the original
Northern Ireland deal signed off by
Boris Johnson at the end of 2020. this
is what about a year and a half of
intense negotiations have led up to and
Rishi soon act allies say he's managed
to secure concessions from the EU
although we haven't seen the detail of
what they will agree today that his
predecessors could not now we expect
they will announce the details of this
agreement at a press conference later
this afternoon a short way from here and
take some questions before the prime
minister is that if all goes to plan
goes to Parliament to announce the deal
later tonight this is all to do with
making it easier to trade between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland to minimize
checks but also solve some of the
political issues the feeling that
Northern Ireland does not in the view of
many who live there have enough of a say
over the EU rules which apply there but
the key question is not just the
agreement today that could be the easy
bit it's the reaction among the
conservative party and among its key
figures such as Boris Johnson and also
of course crucially the reaction in
Northern Ireland because the Prime
Minister has said that he would like to
see Power sharing get back up and
running and that requires all parties to
accept what he agrees here today
um Joe the dup all important in this
they've got their um seven points the
seven tests and just looking at some of
them no bordering the IRSC no checks on
goods between GB and Northern Ireland
are they going to get this over the line
well I think okay perhaps is tomorrow
intubated the easy bit was getting the
deal a difficult bit was uh selling it
and even though this deal could be an
improvement it certainly doesn't mean
that the dup will back it and return to
a power sharing here at Stormwind I
think it's worth uh noting that their
response may not be immediate it may not
be today it may not even be this week
they want to look at the legal text and
perhaps they'll also want to look at the
implementation they will want to see how
this works in practice they're a short
term and long-term considerations of
course short-term electoral
considerations local elections coming up
here in Northern Ireland possibly a
storm election this year will the dup
backing of this deal increase or
decrease their support especially with a
more hard-line units party the TUV uh in
the background potentially benefiting
but the long-term perspective is the
decades ahead the big concern of many
unionists the dup being the largest
unions party here here at a storeman is
that we will see if EU law applies in
Northern Ireland a Divergence
Divergence which could be pretty
damaging for the union permanently
damaging for the union and will would
see potentially Northern Ireland move
further and further away from the rest
of Great Britain now of course it's not
just the dups response we'll be looking
at today but many other parties across
the political Spectrum but K they don't
have a veto over this deal they do have
a veto though here at Stormont and power
sharing will not start start again
unless they approve it and of course
there has not been power sharing here
for more than a year we had elections
last May and still none of those mlas
have sat in Parliament and of course we
don't have a first minister or Deputy
first Minister okay finale thank you
both
well here's what some of the papers are
saying about today's talks that start
with the times quoting Rishi sunak who
says he's won big concessions from the
EU
the telegraph says the Tory Revolt is
brewing as the EU Chief flies into seal
the brexit deal and what does The Daily
Mail say stated and find out a little
bit more meantime Supermarket bosses
have been called in to a meeting with
food Minister Mark Spencer who'll ask
them to explain fruit and veg shortages
and what they're doing to stock empty
shelves uh well let's find out in more
detail but standing by for us uh this
morning hello to you um Saba so talk us
through what the government wants to
hear from the supermarket bosses
good morning K well empty shelves and
customer limits in supermarkets like
this one could be in place for at least
up to a month now that's according to
George Eustis the former environment
secretary he said yesterday that or
rather pointed yesterday that's
particular international issues are
affecting us on a domestic level here in
the UK he said that the war in Ukraine
as we know has significantly impacted uh
heating bills energy costs uh
significantly risen and as a result less
people are willing to heat their
greenhouses which in turn is impacting
production and also what we're seeing is
travel issues and also cold weather in
Morocco and Spain also affecting the
level of imports coming in to the United
Kingdom now Mr Eustis did say that this
is something that the UK government
couldn't really have done much to
prevent from occurring but it was in
fact the national Union of farmers that
said uh just last week that they have
been warning the government about this
scenario taking place at this past year
and that the UK has hit a Tipping Point
now as you say uh the the government are
later meeting with representatives from
the major supermarket brands later today
to talk about what they can do to fix
the current problem that we are seeing
and how to prevent it again from
happening in the future but more details
as the day goes on okay okay thank you
other news off Jim expected to announce
this morning that it will drop its cap
on the amount energy supplies are able
to charge households but analysts
believe bills will still Rise by an
average of 500 pounds uh check this
chart out it shows how wholesale gas
prices spiked after the invasion of
Ukraine but prices have recently come
down as a result it's expected that
offgen will also reduce the energy price
cap to an estimated
3295 pounds it's currently 4
270 pounds despite this bills are still
expected to rise by 20 because the
government's energy price guarantee
which caps household bills at two and a
half thousand pounds annually will rise
to three thousand pounds the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt is Raising calls from
opposition parties to keep the support
at the current level in his spring
budget next month let's take a look at
some of today's other headlines for you
in the meantime police have been granted
more time to question a suspect in the
shooting of an off-duty police officer
in Northern Island detective Chief
Inspector John Caldwell remains in a
critical condition after the suspected
terror attack in Omar on Wednesday so
far six men have been arrested
the age at which people can marry in the
UK goes up today from 16 to 18. the law
also covers civil Partnerships and
parental consent will make no difference
campaigners have long argued that
allowing under 18s to marry left some
young people vulnerable to forced
marriages
the Australian firm recharge Industries
has completed its takeover of British
Vault the collapse startup company had
Ambitions of building a nearly 4 billion
pound battery plant outside blithe in
the Northeast Bart couldn't get enough
funding its new owners say the plant may
still be built one day
Italian authorities say they fear more
than a hundred people may have died
after a boat carrying migrants sank off
the country's southern coast the bodies
of 59 people including 12 children have
been found so far they traveled from
turkey with passengers from Afghanistan
Pakistan and Somalia
the boat sank off the eastern coast of
Calabria in southern Italy the Italian
Coast Guard says dozens of bodies washed
up on the shore in a seaside resort just
south of the coastal town of grotoni our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins has
more for us now um Siobhan's such a
heartbreaking story this
really terrible scenes yesterday off the
coast of Eastern Italy uh we saw the
boat which these people had been
traveling in broken up on the shore uh
fears now as you say at least 100 people
have died the UN in a joint statement
said many of those on board included
whole families children who had
disappeared you can imagine just how
terrible it was going into the water at
night and some of the survivors have
been taken not just for health checks
but also for psychological care because
the trauma that they're feeling is
exceptional and police initially have
said that they are talking to one
alleged Smuggler and last night said
they were looking for another three who
are allegedly involved in this operation
now Italy's far right prime minister who
was voted in last year partly on a
pledge to curb migration to Italy has
expressed her deep sorrow and said that
they will continue to crack down on
illegal migration and trafficking but
this scene has reopened the discussions
around migration particularly following
a discussion and decision last week by
MPS in Italy to tighten rules around
rescues meaning that boats that go into
the Mediterranean to try and save people
aren't allowed to hang around and Carry
Out multiple rescues they have to get a
port and move immediately to it some
people saying that actually that will
mean that more people in the
Mediterranean die and we already know
that that is one of the most dangerous
routes on the planet okay for now thank
you
in other news Nigeria's election results
are trickling out but it could be days
before a new president is announced is
the tightest race since the end of
military rule in 1999.
uh yusra is joining us now hi Israel so
um there were three main candidates
how's it looking
I mean we are in Lagos which is a key
stronghold in the country seven million
people have signed up to vote here and
one of the main contenders known as The
Godfather of Lagos he was the former
Governor here and he's running on the
ticket of the ruling APC party but he's
actually losing to 61 year old former
Banker Peter Obi here in Lagos who's won
17 out of 20 local government
authorities and is actually leading
slightly in the popular boat but it will
still be a few days obviously until
things are really clear but again it's
an incredibly tight race things are
moving in ways that are unexpected Peter
Obi has galvanized the youth Vote many
of the young people that we've met here
have said that he is their guy he is the
one that will bring about change at a
time where change is much needed there
have been issues with the economy that
are hitting people in their day-to-day
there's been a massive cash shortage
fuel scarcity but also really high
unemployment among the youth that is
actually really
oh
I think we might have lost it but we're
getting uh the point we won't know who
the president is in Nigeria for a few
days to come of course we'll update you
soon as we have more information on that
meantime Israeli settlers have torched
Palestinian cars and homes in the
northern West Bank after a Palestinian
gunman killed two Israeli Brothers
Israel's dance about a meeting in Jordan
where Israeli and Palestinian officials
jointly pledged to de-escalate the
latest surge in violence Hamas which
governs the Gaza Strip called the
meetings worthless and condemned its
rivals in the Palestinian Authority for
taking part
the ex-husband and former in-laws of a
Hong Kong model have been charged with
her murder Abby choi's dismembered body
was found on Friday the 28 year old's
case has gripped the Chinese territory
since her disappearance last week
California being battered by what the
National Weather Service says is one of
the strongest storms ever to hit the
state 45 inches of snow fell in the Big
Bear Lake area in 72 hours in Los
Angeles forecasters have warned of flush
flooding and also mudslides
and this is a moment that A motorhome
fell into the Santa Clara River just
north of Los Angeles the swollen River
carved into an embankment near a holiday
park and caused it to collapse
speaking to friends in California over
the weekend they've had to move out of
their house because it's so cold and
they don't have any central heating
they've never checked it worked in 20
years before there you go that's how
cold it is speaking to the lib Dems
leaders that Ed Davey who is urging
ministers to scrap the energy price cap
rise
next hour the shadow Chancellor Rachel
Reese will be here to talk about her
boss growth mission
and at 8 20 I'll get Phil rycroft's
thoughts on the looming Northern Ireland
trade deal he was the permanent
secretary at the brexit department
remember when it was oven ready now the
conservative MP and member of the
Northern Ireland Affairs committee is
Sir Robert Buckland is here with this
one hey how are you it's nice to see you
as always is it still going to go ahead
well it sounds like it I mean I'm
hearing been here before well we have
many times and I think a lot of us have
got the scars on our back on on brexit
it does sound as if it is happening your
first year of Wonderland is coming over
this afternoon then it does look like
that the the British government and the
EU have agreed a deal which I think is
really positive news for the people of
Northern Ireland because anything that
helps to deal with the bureaucracy and
the disruption that is caused to
businesses by this these checks between
Great Britain and Northern Ireland I
think is a very positive step forward
it's not a deal unless the dup agree
though is it well I very much hope that
the dup will approve what comes out of
the package I'm hearing that there are
potential developments on vat and state
subsidies which are big issues as well
for uh the relationship between the EU
and and the UK but I I think now is the
time for us to press ahead with a much
needed change I think that we need to
think about citizens in Northern Ireland
and their lives and the reality of life
on the ground in Northern Ireland and
work together for uh that change and
whilst it'd be great to have the dup on
board I think now is the time for us to
get on with those reforms from what
you're saying um out can we glean that
the dup is not all-powerful like it was
previously
well look I'm sure the dupmps and mlas
themselves would not claim to be
all-powerful I think what they would say
is that they are a couple of deals
before well I mean we remember when of
course they held the balance of power in
that hun Parliament back in 17 that
isn't the case anymore but it's not the
case that they are being marginalized
and also there's a wider issue here
about unionist opinion uh within
Northern Ireland you know there are many
strands of uh opinion that support Union
with Great Britain with the UK but who
might take a more pragmatic view should
we say or of the need for some
compromise here you know we must let the
perfect be the enemy of the goods I'm
sure that this deal will probably have
some unanswered questions and maybe not
solve all the issues in one Fell Swoop
but it does sound as if it's going to be
a big step forward that means then we
don't have to take this unilateral
action here in the UK with a Northern
Ireland protocol bill that's currently
before Parliament it sends us to the
prime minister's already got the top off
his Mont Blanc fountain pen but surely
it needs to go to a vote in the house
here's the thing I think technically it
probably doesn't because I think this is
that's not really the point though well
I understand politics okay around a long
time I I think if I were the government
I'd probably be making time for a debate
and for some sort of vote that can be
held by members but I do think that as a
matter of law it is important to
remember that we put into place
mechanisms in the U withdrawal act back
in 2020 that allow for these things to
have direct effect through that already
established legislative pipeline so
let's not get too hung up about this but
the idea that some omps aren't going to
have their say is I think for the birds
I'm sure we're going to hear a lot of uh
opinion in the next few days so you
think there will be a vote well I think
there'll be some sort of vote I I think
because the ERG will want to vote people
like Boris Johnson as Wella brathaman
who are agitating in the background they
will all want to vote yeah but the
government is right to say that they've
already established the statutory
pipeline through which any uh treaty
treaties what does that mean for the
Prime Minister well I think it means the
prime minister is able to do his deal uh
and and actually act in the interest of
the people of Northern Ireland and I
think that whilst Parliament is
obviously hugely important in all of
that I think that uh ultimately you know
the government has got to be in a
position where it is able to make these
International agreements and then make
them stick and I'm sure that the
majority of the conservative party will
want the prime minister to understand
that but the Prime Minister
um has to keep the troublemakers on side
well yes it does but also this is about
leadership and I think when you are in
these positions of leadership taking
some risks uh taking difficult decisions
grasping Nettles if you like is a really
important part of what it is to be a
leader and I think the prime minister is
demonstrating that at the moment I very
much hope that he succeeds it will be a
demonstration of his resolution and his
ability to under big pressure make those
big calls but you can only lead if you
have the support of your back benches
well I think the majority of bat benches
will rally round I think that whilst
it's important to hear the voices of
everybody who who like me has been Deep
In The Weeds of all of this I think
ultimately looking at the bigger picture
we've got to put ourselves in the shoes
of the people of Northern Ireland
remember that it is their interest that
we need to serve the interests of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement to make
sure that that peace process isn't
undermined by any damage to the
north-south Border but at the same time
no damage to the East-West border which
is of course an important strand of that
1998 agreement okay here come all the
acronyms the dup saying seven tests
including no border in the Irish sea no
checks on goods between GB and I and if
they don't support what's going forward
then the ERG
another European research group another
acronym for you they are not going to um
support it because they want the dup to
be happy so where does that leave the
prime minister
well I I I think the seven tests being
having been developed last year were an
important moment for the dup uh I've yet
to see and I think all of us have yet to
see the detail of that deal maybe I'll
be the dup keep their Council of some
performance well I think it'll be a vast
Improvement in where we were if we have
red and green Lanes I think I think the
problem here okay is that we have a
unique situation in Northern Ireland we
have a peace process we've got to
maintain that north-south border must
never be a hard border and that does
mean that the rules of the single Market
do start to blend in a you know rather
unusual and perhaps in elegant way with
the rules and the laws of the United
Kingdom there therefore needs to be a
compromise I think within those seven
tests the dup I think do understand that
this is a unique position and
um you know we've now in early 2023 it's
we've moved on I think the position that
meant that the government was right back
in June last year to bring forward its
own unilateral legislation here in
Parliament has changed that the fact
we're having meaningful negotiations the
fact that EU themselves acknowledge
problems with the protocol I think was a
big step forward and that does mean that
we're now in a place where we can
normalize relations which will have
wider implications for the UK we can
start to do business on small boats for
example if we can get this deal over the
line to be an oven ready deal and no
border whatsoever in the Irish sea
that's what a previous conservative
prime minister promised us well I I
would say that in the main we got the
absolute deal we wanted I think the
protocol was always going to be a
problem I think that some of the uh
practical effects of the protocol have
now demonstrated real dislocation of
course not all of the protocol has even
been brought into Force yet and I think
that would be an even more problematic
situation to be Einstein to realize it
was going to be a problem well I don't
think any of us were denying the fact
that this was a complex and a unique
situation in Northern Ireland but what I
think it is encouraging to see is the
government prepared to seize the
initiative get on with those meaningful
negotiations and now hopefully today we
can see uh them bearing fruit so
how come
potentially a Russian student can get
this over the line and Boris Johnson
couldn't
well look that was a big sign I'm not
answering this question I'm not in the
room okay I'm not in the room I don't
have the advantage this time of being in
the rooms where where you know decisions
are made or information is is is is
passed on what I would say is that I
think this prime minister has been able
to create a relationship of trust uh I
think it's about personalities well
sometimes politics is and you know this
isn't a reflection on previous Prime
Ministers particularly you know if you
get on well with people and win their
trust then I I think in all our
experiences more business can be done
and I think the relationship with the
French president has probably improved I
think there is that willingness well I
think I I haven't been in a room with
either them together but but I
understand that there is a good personal
chemistry and that the relationship is a
healthy one that's really important if
we are to make progress on things like
small boats okay I think it's vital for
the interests of the UK at this time of
economic pressure that we are able to
show the world that we capable of making
deals and agreements like the one I hope
will emerge this week and I think that
is good not just for Northern Ireland
but also good for Britain's reputation
in the world our relationship with the
United States and indeed The Wider
position of Britain so that's why I'm
willing the Prime Minister on and I very
much hope that a deal can be reached so
just to clarify we've got a conservative
prime minister who is finally listening
to what the European Union has to say
well I think they're listening to us as
well I think this time last year the
commission and indeed other governments
the Irish government weren't really in a
position where they were prepared to
admit that there was a problem with the
protocol that changed we heard much more
positive noises from the Irish
government and the EU themselves then
showed a willingness to share data and
to come to the negotiating table for
those formal talks I think both sides
have shown a willingness to compromise
and to come to a sensible agreement and
that's why I think we should be
welcoming the news today I just clarify
why do we cite a deal if we thought that
it wasn't the right deal
well if you remember back in 2019 I
think we were in a position where we
really needed to get a deal over the
line I think that in the main I think
that deal was an extremely sensible one
for the United Kingdom we got brexit
done in early 2020 we created that
transition period we got a trade
agreement that indeed in many elements
was was a deeper Trade Agreement than
perhaps people had originally thought
I'd love to go further I'd like to see
more subjects covered like financial
services for example in the future but I
do remembering uh opposition at the time
I think it was very important that we
got a deal with the EU and managed to
keep that timetable which bearing in
mind the previous frustrations that we'd
seen about brexit was indeed an
achievement of Boris Johnson how can you
say we've got brexit done when was it
was where we are today
well I think I think the very Factor
brexit has been done but here's the
thing hey I think our relationship with
the EU will be a continuing negotiation
they're geographically next door to us
we have a lot of trade and relationships
in common between them we will continue
to talk bilaterally with the EU and
frankly that's what I want to see I
think the idea that somehow we shut up
shop and say well thank you very much
we're not going to be talking to you
anymore is I think uh rather a dangerous
concept I want to see more meaningful
discussions with the EU in future so
that we can enjoy that healthy bilateral
relationship outside of the institutions
of Brussels it's Robert it's always
great to see you thank you for joining
us thank you coach appreciate it thank
you quick look at the weather if you're
not here on Sky
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days will be largely dry and
settle but it's going to be chilly with
widespread overnight Frost
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
at Sci-Fi Action Adventure film
everything everywhere all at once has
set a new record at this year's Screen
Actors Guild Awards scooping up four
major trophies uh they included best
ensemble in a motion picture and best
female actor for Michelle yeoh Brendan
Fraser also had a good night winning
outstanding actor in a film for his role
in the whale and the cast of HBO's
immensely popular the White Lotus won
best or stormed in a drama series with
Jennifer Coolidge taking outstanding
female actress in a drama series we'll
have more on those Awards later on this
hour
now people living in a picturesque
Cornish town have deployed their musical
talents in an effort to recruit a new GP
a too much
[Music]
and 500 people living in the time played
a part in the music video it shows off
the child's charms in what the community
admits is an increasingly desperate
attempt to bring in a new doctor as
traditional adverts have failed
beautiful shots from last night
[Music]
tell you about some fantastic pictures
weren't we before the break stargazers
were treated to a rare sighting across
the sky last night as the northern
lights were visible across much of the
UK also known as the Aurora Borealis the
spectacular displays are usually only
seen in the Arctic Circle but this was
the view from Air beach in Scotland
amazing it's caused by a combination of
different gases and the effects of the
Earth's magnetic field that make up the
colors and wave patterns but you knew
that didn't you
this was from County Durham spectacular
curtain of red and green filling the
skies there
and remarkably the display was seen as
far side as Oxford as you can see from
these pictures good news for those who
missed it the Met Office say there'll be
more of it this evening though if you've
ever tried to chase the Northern Lights
you'll know that they are incredibly
unpredictable
top stories for you this morning
Wishy sunak is preparing for a final
talks with EU commission president ursul
Vander Lyon on the Northern Ireland
protocol conservative MP Sir Robert
Buckland predicted on this program that
any agreement would be subject to a vote
in the House of Commons
Supermarket bosses have been called to a
meeting with food Minister Mark Spencer
who will tell them to get the shell
stocked
off gem expected to announce a drop in
its energy prize caps at nine o'clock
but it won't mean lower bills for
households
final brexit talks are due to take place
with a deal expected today which could
cut red tape and make trade easier
across the Irish see earlier I spoke to
Sir Robert Buckland member of the
Northern Ireland Affairs committee
I think now is the time for us to press
ahead with a much needed change I think
that we need to think about citizens in
Northern Ireland and their lives and the
reality of life on the ground in
Northern Ireland uh and work together
for uh that change and whilst it'd be
great to have the dup on board I think
now is the time for us to to get on with
those reforms
I'll have more on that throughout the
morning let's turn now to another big
challenge for the government should we
energy bills off gem we'll announce a
drop in its energy price cap at nine
o'clock but households are still
expecting higher bills from April Carly
Newman is a single mum with a young son
hey Carly it's good to see you thanks
for joining us tell us about the impact
that energy prices have had on you
um yeah that this winter we've obviously
seen the increase like everyone else
um we've uh I've also had quite a bit of
like mold and damp so I've had to have
um uh dehumidifier on as well as the
heating so that's been very expensive
um and it's still cold right so I'm I'm
thinking the the bills are going to
continue to stay at this price for a
while but um they're obviously likely to
increase
um over the next month or so
um tell us what the last year has been
like for you though we can see the
little one is there with you obviously
um prior you know keeping the house warm
you're talking about the mold there
keeping the high storm has been a big
challenge for you
um the energy price guarantee ends in
April and the energy bill support scheme
also scaled back in April so how's that
going to impact on you
yeah a lot um and you know I'm fortunate
that they coincide at the same time
government have a habit of bad timing
like this um and that that support's
obviously been very useful to me
um it has helped with my bills when
they've come in
um are quite eye-wateringly at least you
know that that discount is sorry am I
boring you
um is is applied um so actually that
that has been quite helpful and for that
I'm quite worried about that going
because it will it does make a
difference to me and what I'm able to to
do I think it will just like many people
see energy debts increasing
yeah I mean when you look at how much
centrica who won British gas made in
profits 3.3 billion pounds last year and
then look at Shell they made profits of
32.2 billion pounds how does that make
you feel when you're worrying about
whether to put the heating on or not
yeah it just feels it well it feels
quite criminal really and I I you know
still I think I've been saying it for a
while not I don't understand how it's
still allowed to happen
um my understanding is also that the the
cost of um like low I don't understand
enough about how it works but the the
overall wholesale cost has gone down so
energy companies
um are you know the fuel isn't expensive
the energy isn't expensive for them to
buy so I'm not sure why then the cap is
changing um and it isn't change it isn't
being reflected onto US
yeah
um the government
um so far has had a windfall tax on gas
and oil companies
um but and they're sort of shying away
from any anything more than that at this
stage what would you say
um just
um I'll just say I don't really
understand how it's it's allowed to
continue how are these companies making
such huge profits
um when lots and lots of families
um are struggling lots and lots of
families are going into debt debt that
you know with energy companies it's it's
well all debt is scary to have but
particularly you know with with energy
companies having that sort of like
threatening over you that energy
companies can take away your um energy
Supply at any moment
um particularly now when it's you know
really cold
um and that's affecting lots of people
you know people that have maybe never
been in debt before how is that like
justifiable how is that being allowed
what's he saying he's saying he's cold
but he's wearing very fleecy pajamas
okay look after your mum
bye
thanks very much bye bye bye
bye Village in Norfolk as soon as beachy
Road by three meters in just two days
leaving houses at risk of collapse
Lifeboat access to hemsby has been cut
off with a beach expected to be closed
for the foreseeable future Adele husband
a deceiving calm as the edge of a
community crumbles into the sea
Daniel runs the Lifeboat service here
now out of action and the beach is
closed after two nights of high winds
and Tides tore into the coast it just
seems there's no matter of urgency to
anything along this Coastline and how
urgent is it all right surgeon to me
I've said this needs to her now not in
two years time this should have been
done five years ago we've lost so much
of this coastline
homes are at risk too a quarter of
Mary's back Gardens being lost to the
Sea we was told to expect to move out
but um
we took our chances
if it Carries On
I can't even I don't know how long I
don't know it depends on who helps and
who doesn't
need someone to help us
in 30 years hemsby beach has lost around
100 meters a telegraph Pole now Teeters
on the edge
the geology of some areas makes them
more vulnerable than others here on the
east coast of England it's particularly
at risk because it's made up of a
mixture of soft clay and sand Which is
less resistant than the harder rock
found over in the west now it's an
inevitability erosion has always
happened but what's different is the
process is accelerating and many believe
that that is down to climate change
the amount of government money allocated
to Coastal erosions risen but there's a
feeling action isn't in step with the
urgency of a changing landscape we have
sea levels that are rising faster now
because of global warming and that means
that we will see more of this kind of
thing happening in the future but I
would emphasize that this is as much a
problem with a communication problem a
planning problem a question of having
honest conversations in communities so
that people understand what's going on
full coastal areas
action and an acceptance we can't turn
the tide of erosion Adele Robinson Sky
News Norfolk
I said Davey's here with us to talk
about all sorts of things but primarily
of course the Northern Ireland protocol
what would you like to see in any deal
well I want to make sure we sort out the
trading relationships liberal Democrats
want to make sure there is a deal
because that would be good for Northern
Ireland it'd be good for the whole of
the UK economy the government's failure
to deliver a deal for months years now
has been a real break on economic
success so if the deal makes sense the
Democrats go back here and what does
making sense look like to the liberal
Democrats well we need to make sure that
the barriers to trade are got rid of
that there is a deal that all parties
can sign up to we talked to parties in
Northern Ireland a lot to make sure
we're getting the Grassroots opinion
from businesses and people of Northern
Ireland and our sister party the
alliance are very keen on a deal we take
that into huge consideration because
they and the people they present the
most affected by it so we'll be
listening to people in Northern Ireland
but we also need to take account of
British business as well sure I mean the
alliance partying the dup very different
views on what should be in this deal uh
the dup saying they don't want any
Border in the Irish sea brexit means
there has to be a border somewhere
well indeed that is the logic of of
brexit and the danger is that if we
don't sort this out the level of
investment in Northern Ireland the
investment in our own country uh we'll
just go down and down and down and let's
face it our economy is in a mess at the
moment we at the bottom of the league
for growth I regret to say because of
this government's failed economic
policies and that's bad for people it's
part of the reason why people are
finding it so hard to make ends no but
you're taking me away from my point this
morning um if I may have said and that
is what is going to happen with the dup
primarily and thus the ERG
European research group they do not want
to border in the Irish sea what we're
being told is that there will be or be a
soft border but there will be a border
in the Irish sea well you're absolutely
right the dup and many conservative back
Ventures have been quite ideological
about this they're not being pragmatic
and I think when you listen to business
people and to the represent other
representatives in Northern Ireland they
want a pragmatic solution they want to
move on it seems the conservative party
is just incapable of doing that and
that's very damaging to our reputation
it's very damaging for our economy so I
hope there can be agreement with the dup
and the ERG from the conservatives
coming on board we'll see if Rishi sunak
has managed that what he can know is he
puts a reasonable deal on the table
there were Democrat MPS will support
that even if his conservative uh
supposedly colleagues vote against him
you might not get a say in it he doesn't
need to take it to Parliament he doesn't
absolutely need to in terms of
constitution but I think politically he
needs to I think most MPS if not all MPS
and certainly voters would think it'd be
extraordinary for him to do this huge
deal and not to allow the elector
representatives of people's
representatives to have a say
how do you think he's managed to get
this far with the European Union and
people like Liz truss and um Boris
Johnson have not
well I will see when he puts forward the
deal we'll be scrutinizing it line by
line of course that's our job
um I just hope he has made found some
pragmatic Way Forward it is so damaging
not to have this deal and sometimes
people will think well it doesn't really
matter it's normal it does matter not
just to the people of Northern Ireland
but to our ability to move on in our
relationship with Europe that's been
very damaging this this ampass over
Northern Ireland it's prevented us
enabling many of our businesses to have
better entry into the European uh
economy and that's hampering our our
wider successes as a as an economy so we
really need a deal we need it soon and
the failure of the conservatives whether
it's been Johnson trust and now soon act
to deliver that has been a real failure
of government Sir Robert Buckland a
conservative previous cabinet secretary
now on the Northern Ireland select
committee saying to a certain level um
has managed to get further than the
other two because of Personality
politics
quite possibly to be honest that's up to
the conservatives so there seems to be a
battle between Personalities in the
conservatives and the reason why I think
that's very reprehensible and wrong is
there are millions of families and
pensions out there who are suffering
suffering with the cost of living
suffering with energy bills and little
Democrats keep arguing that government
should should focus on the issues that
matter to people whether it's the cost
of living energy bills whether it's the
NHS crisis and the government keeps
taking its eye of the ball and seem
completely out of touch with the real
problems that people are facing to that
end you are suggesting a bonanza bonus
what's that all about well there's a
bonanza bonus being enjoyed by the
bosses of the oil and gas companies and
we think that that should be taxed along
with the windfall tax on the profits the
flips out of the win full tax okay yeah
because you know we need more help for
people struggling with energy bills and
the government at the moment despite
millions of people uh struggling are
proposing to increase People's Energy
bills by another 500 pounds this April
they you know in my decision is what
people who who can't afford their rent
uh we're seeing a large number of uh
large increase in the numbers of people
going to food banks that's the reality
and yet the government are going to
increase the cost of living what liberal
Democrats are saying is no we actually
should be cutting uh the energy bills
for people they're not
um increasing the the bills by 500
pounds what they're doing is taking away
um a temporary support structure that
was in place no well the support
structure called the energy price
guarantee is currently two and a half
thousand pounds which means the average
household will pay only two and a half
thousand pounds only huge amount the
concert is proposing despite this cost
of living emergency to increase it to
three thousand pounds some people
actually see their energy bills go up by
900 pounds with this conservative
package so what liberal Democrats are
saying is no use the money that you have
saved government that you could put
aside for this uh support but keep it
there and if you do and you have a
proper windfall tax you can afford both
to cut everyone's energy bills by a lot
by reducing the NG price guarantee and
give more money to businesses who are
struggling and indeed the least well off
so we have a complete package properly
funded completely affordable which would
cut inflation and boost growth
is economics after all then no no let's
trust as economics were to give the
better off a lot more money we're not
doing that our money will be targeted at
the least well support with our energy
bills well her scheme was just not
affordable because you saw uh the huge
increase in borrowing what Alf alphan is
Affordable our proposals are affordable
because we use the money that Jeremy
Hunt put aside but he wants to screw it
away in the treasury we're saying keep
it there to help people with their
energy bills talk to me about
um Dominic Robb um he says that if he is
found guilty as far as bullying claims
are concerned then he will resign
I think you should if he's found guilty
um we all wait a report I think we've
all been shocked by the number of
complaints but I think it's only fair to
to see what the investigation
um finds because previously you had
suggested had you not that he should
step aside until the report yeah and I
still think that um I I think it's been
quite wrong that as Justice secretary
Above All Justice secretary he's been
serving there despite these huge number
of complaints I think in any other Walk
of Life people would have had to step
down during the investigation I think
it's been wrong that he's been in his
post during this very serious
investigation and just before I let you
go
um how do you think the lib Dems are
going to get on in Scotland now that
Nicholas sturgeon is stepping aside
well you know uh Nicola sturgeon I think
has admirers from across the parties
um she was the first woman uh first
minister in Scotland and while I and my
little Democrats disagree with her on
many many issues one couldn't help
admire the fact that she got to where
she she was
um the implications I think though for
the liberal Democrats are pretty
positive we're finding on the doorstep
that not just because Nicholas
sturgeon's stood down but the smp's
failures in government in Hollywood more
generally a lot of support is coming to
us in places like Edinburgh places like
the Highland and Islands we're seeing a
big uptake in support for the liberal
Democrats coming from former SMP
supporters and former conservative
supporters okay are you a movie guy a
moviegoer well during the short recess I
went to see Puss in Boots The Last Wish
with my daughter
I wasn't it was great fun she really
enjoyed it good apparently the one to
watch is everything everywhere all at
once yeah and I saw that I was gonna go
I don't I'm not sure I take my daughter
to see it there I wouldn't it's good to
see you as always thanks a good question
let's talk about it in more detail
though um should we um award-winning
film producer Walter mirrish we'll talk
about that first and then I'm going to
tell you about the um Saga awards from
last night which is sort of a precursor
to the Oscars if you will
um anyway as I was telling you he's been
appraised as a true Visionary and
industry leader now to his death at the
age of 101.
[Music]
in America
famous for Classics like West Side Story
and Some Like It Hot he won the best
picture Oscar for 1967s In the Heat of
the Night the academy announced
Mauritius death saying his passion for
filmmaking never wavered
as promised let's talk about the Saga
Awards now Ashanti omker is here to talk
about last night's Screen Actors guilder
Awards hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program so the
movie I was just talking to Sir Ed about
everything everywhere all at once does
it deserve all the awards absolutely 100
I am beaming because I I stayed up
actually to watch the ceremony and the
winds just feel so good to me especially
with Michelle yo being the first Asian
woman to win at the song Awards and
kihui Kwan who also has won for this
film plus this film itself winning feels
so good for representation matters
uh Jamie Lee Curtis
um finally nominated for an Academy
Award she won for best supporting
actress last night and she did indeed
and Her speech just also you know it had
lots of emotions for me not only did she
look great in that red outfit she talked
about nepotism she talked about how hard
she's worked everything she said on
stage felt great and she also got the
whole crowd chanting for Michelle yew
which also was just really magnificent
yeah tell me about White Lotus I've
Loved White Lotus
oh gosh for this winning outstanding
performance in an ensemble series that
actually is glorious because it is such
a tough production to to make and every
time it's it keeps winning the awards
because it has some amazing talent in it
and Jennifer Coolidge she has been
winning these Awards it's great to see
that her time has come and for this as
an ensemble to win just is is fantastic
um now top gun Maverick one of the top
grossing movies of last year how come
movies like that don't get nominated
you know what it is the pet peeve of
mine I'll be honest because action
movies are the ones that get people into
Cinemas superhero movies get people into
Cinemas people are contributing the fans
are contributing to the box office and a
lot of the time the awards voters are
slightly snooty about these and it does
it does bug me because I am a Critics
Choice voter and there's a Critics
Choice super Awards where you have you
know action horror all these genres that
kind of get under under the the line of
of these big award ceremonies and it's
just wonderful to see this because this
stumped Ensemble that Tom Cruise put
together with with with this film top
gun Maverick literally got the people
into the cinemas there wasn't CGI he did
this you know with a rigorous process he
made sure he could dunk these people
underwater to make sure they could
actually do these roles everything that
they did to make this film was so
magnificent I'm really glad that it has
has had a chance in the spotlight and I
really hope that this changes as things
go along because they're working really
hard on these movies and they're not
getting as acknowledged as they should
be well they get paid a lot of money
though don't they so I suppose that's
some acknowledgment for some um Ashanti
just before I let you go looking over
the horizon to the Oscars any
predictions
oh I have a feeling that Angela Bassett
might win at the Oscars and I have a
feeling everything everywhere all at
once will do very well again and
Michelle you I feel has that chance now
that she has won the SAG award because
it was a little kind of dicey between
her and Kate Blanchett this time around
but with her winning at the SAG I have a
feeling the Oscars will also be a clean
sweep for her okay it's good to talk to
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you so much everything
everywhere all at once is the one that
is predicted to do incredibly well at
the Oscars coming up in the next hour
we're going to be talking about the
Northern Ireland protocol what does that
actually mean to you what will it mean
for the Prime Minister will he take it
to a vote in the House of Commons if he
doesn't what impact will that have on
his future career what about a border in
the Irish sea we were told by a previous
prime minister that that was never ever
ever going to happen under a
conservative government it looks as
though potential really a soft border
down the Irish sea is now very much on
the cards what does labor think of all
that we'll tell you in just a few
moments time to stay tuned our way
[Music]